[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec ali
girard experts numériques vous êtes
également ancien maire adjoint de seront
chargés à l'époque du développement
économique et numériques bonsoir à vous
ali gérard merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés cyril d'helmand chercheur à
l'institut thomas more
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être avec
nous donc une soixantaine de maires à on
le disait de députés qui partent en
guerre contre le déploiement de la 5g
pas d'étude d'impact climatique et
environnementale aucune concept aux
consultations publiques préalables sur
ce dossier vous comprenez tout de même
leur inquiétude et ligier à écouter en
fait je pense que concernant les
débouchés de la sagem on est tous
d'accord sur le fait une grosse avancée
technologique qui va permettre
effectivement des usages nouveaux et des
avancées à importante au niveau
industriel
par contre effectivement comme vous
l'avait annoncé dans notre reportage on
a des conséquences au terme de haut
niveau de la santé qui sont incertaines
l'organisent l'organisation mondiale de
la santé a elle même parle elle-même de
dangerosité par rapport aux ondes
électromagnétiques
et c'est vrai que concernant le la 5g on
utilise en fait des ondes de haute
fréquence qui transportent plus
d'énergie que des ondes basses
fréquences et donc le rayonnement est
beaucoup plus important avec voilà des
conséquences incertaines sur les
molécules
c'est la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'un débat plus
sûr plus clair sur ce sujet là de la
santé puisque effectivement on ne peut
pas accepter une innovation
technologique au détriment de la santé
de nos compatriotes alors parmi les
maires qui coince sur la 5g martine
aubry à lille et connaissons truite
regarder parce que nous doutes
persistent tant du point de vue
sanitaire que de la sobriété numérique
sur le déploiement de la 5g
nous avons voté au conseil municipal ce
soir un moratoire
il est urgent d'attendre il est urgent
d'attendre alors c'est vrai que c'est
pas la première fois qu'on évoque les
éventuels problèmes
de santé publique si lille d'helmand est
ce qu'il y à des études clair sur ce
point parce que ça reste le grand flou
et c'est extrêmement embêtant bien
évidemment des études clair non
manifestement il y en a pas il ya
plusieurs études faire peuvent être
contradictoires il y à la leyre feu de
l'eau à naître en confirmant à
l'électromagnétisme par contre on aurait
peut-être simplement à regarder déjà
l'impact de la 4g sur les populations
manifestement une personne aujourd'hui
n'est capable de déterminer qui a un
impact négatif ne va pas donc
effectivement la fréquence maison n'est
pas la même mais aujourd'hui personne et
est en capacité et notamment à long
terme de dire s'il y aura des impacts
négatifs ou s'il y en a pas c'est pour
moi c'est pas c'est pas vraiment le
point le plus bloquants actuellement
alors on va vous demander évidemment
qu'elle est pour un plus bloquants pour
vous mais quand même et ligia ça paraît
incroyable on nous dit on sait pas si
c'est dangereux ou non
enfin bon voilà on va la lancer quand
même c'est comment ça peut arriver dans
un pays en l'occurrence comme la france
écoutez je crois que martine aubry a
demandé un moratoire sur sur le sujet et
que des élus s'inquiètent parce que les
élus sont responsables de la santé de
leurs concitoyens
donc effectivement c'est un sujet qu'il
faut prendre au jeu
le gouvernement a accusé le gouvernement
laisse faire il ya le lancement officiel
aujourd'hui est ce que ça vous semble
normal à partir du moment où il ya un
doute sur la santé publique
moi je crois qu'il faut pas aller trop
vite vous savez l'innovation elle nous
tire vers le haut elle nous tire de
nouveaux usagers vers des choses qui
permettait justement d'avancé mais je
crois qu'il faut pas aller trop vite et
la santé on le voit bien on est en
pleine crise de co lead on a des des
commerçants qui sont fermées des
entreprises aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont
pas ouvertes justement par des à cause
de problématiques de santé
je crois que la santé on a bien vu
aujourd'hui avec la commune 19 que c'est
un enjeu absolument oui jeu halo en un
petit problème de liaison avec ali gia
avant de rétablir la liaison avec vous
alliez jr je vous propose d'écouter
xavier niel a pour lui on ne doit pas
avoir peur de la scène j'ai écouté la 5g
ne doit pas faire peur c'est une
formidable opportunité pour construire
une société plus sobre plus efficace
avec une gestion de la ville améliorer
ce serait dommage en france d'avoir les
meilleurs réseaux fixes avec les offres
fibres les plus rapides d'europe et
d'être le dernier européen sur le mobile
en refusant le marché de la 5g xavier
niel lui qui est rassurant
spécialiste de la téléphonie évidemment
vous a nié saviez niel entre autres
choses cyril d'allemands tout à l'heure
j'ai seulement essayé c'est pas
forcément les questions de santé qui me
font le plus peur alors qu'est ce qui
vous fait le plus peur c'est là la force
de stratégie de déploiement
d'anticipation la force de stratégie
économique de plan économique hier par
rapport à la fin juin
on voit que les premières phases de test
on a quand même 35 métropole alors que
la changer et quand même vendu pour
participer à au désenclavement numérique
j'ai du mal à comprendre que dans le
cerveau de nos énarques il peut pas
aider pas émergé l'idée
de faire une phase de test sur une ville
moyenne une petite ville aujourd'hui
n'est pas n'est pas fibrés ben c'est ça
c'est un point qui me semble quand même
majeurs d'autre part au niveau de mes
inquiétudes c'est que vous avez aucun
vendeur de smartphones européen dans les
12 premiers vendeurs mondiaux de
smartphones vous avez bien sûr pas
français il n'y a pas de stratégie pour
niveau avant au niveau de l'industrie
française
en ce qui concerne les objets connectés
on a le problème des antennes on n'a
toujours pas réglé le problème de you et
on a l'impression en fait de la
cavalerie polonaise qui chargent des
blindés allemands
on repart avec rien et on va lancer une
technologie un qui est effectivement
très prometteuse et qui pourrait être
une source de développement d'industries
françaises mais qui risque de devenir en
fait le point d'entrée et de
développement de toutes les entreprises
étrangères et les entreprises françaises
et européennes vont rester sur le bas
côté
donc c'est ça m'inquiète beaucoup plus
que de potentialités de potentiel pardon
danger sur la santé qui aujourd'hui ne
sont absolument pas avéré
si on utilise cette rhétorique en fait
le moteur à explosion en lorée lane et
développer ces polluants ça peut générer
des problèmes de santé ça produit des
particules fines bon heureusement je
dirais qu'on a développé le moteur à
explosion
donc pour moi le problème n'est pas sur
ces tests et de santé après faire des
moratoires sur tout ce qui à tout ce qui
peut poser un problème en partant du
principe de précaution
eh bien on voit que ta peau tannée dans
la gestion d'actifs sanitaires et
l'hygiène c'était intéressant cet
argumentaire de cyril d'helmand la porte
d'entrée pour les entreprises étrangères
alors que la france finalement restauré
sur le bas-côté vous partagez ce
diagnostic et cette crainte
oui je partage ce diagnostic c'est vrai
qu'on parle de souveraineté nationale et
que le débat de la 5g ne doit pas se
limiter essentiellement un choix entre
des technologies
chinoise il faut le dire ou des
technologies américaines et
malheureusement c'est qui c'est ce qui
risque de se passer on le voit
aujourd'hui dans les pays on l'a vu en
italie par exemple des partenariats qui
sont faits entre justement les
opérateurs et les fournisseurs de
matériel chinois on voit effectivement
que on va on va vers ce verset vers
cette destinée par contre mon inquiétude
également donc on parlait de la santé
mais également là c'est la question de
l'énergie et de la transition
énergétique
vous savez le numérique aujourd'hui
c'est 4 % de la consommation électrique
mondiale pour comparer un petit peu
l'aviation qui consomment beaucoup
d'énergie c'est 3% avec 7,5 g et votre
reportage l'a dit on va démultiplier la
consommation énergétique
on va à des as des as des as démontra
absolument incroyable cette consommation
va augmenter de 25% au niveau mondial et
donc effectivement ça pose la question
de l'écologie et de la transition
énergétique
ensuite il faut pas je pense limiter ce
débat entre la liberté ceux qui sont
pour ceux qui sont contre la 5g je crois
qu'il faut trouver un juste équilibre et
je rejoins votre votre intervenant sur
effectivement qui qui explique cette
avancée de la 5g sur un certain nombre
de sujets notamment sur la création
d'emplois sur des débouchés d'autres
débouchés sur la question des objets
connectés
la question de l'eau tome 2 de
l'automobile qui sera autonome mais on
ne devra pas encore il faut à faire
toutes ces avancées au détriment de la
santé
il ne faut pas aller plus vite que la
musique aujourd'hui encore une fois on
se rend compte que nous sommes dans une
crise sanitaire cette crise sanitaire va
a mis en branle notre économie il ne
faudrait pas qu'à 5 j'ai justement et
des conséquences importantes sur la
santé je pense qu'il faut attendre et
être sûr que cette technologique
innovante et qui est assez exceptionnel
puisque nous permettre d'avancer très
vite série l'allemand le mode de la fin
pour vous par à quoi on continue un
grand débat sera nécessaire selon vous
non pas du tout à un grand une
anticipation une véritable stratégie
elle est indispensable aujourd'hui à
etats unis ont un plan stratégique qui a
totalement à efficient dans leur vision
du numérique mondiale la chine a un plan
stratégique extrêmement offensif
extrêmement documenté extrêmement
pertinent avec une stratégie de
puissance stratégie de souveraineté à un
marché qui fermait faut bien savoir que
la chine n'a pas d'économie de marché
qui est qui pratiquent le dumping
alors que l'union européenne aujourd'hui
elle est ouverte aux quatre-vents c'est
un marché qui a été conçu dans une forme
d'absolutisme une logique des conditions
favorables mais c'est un marché qui tue
pourrait fonctionner si c'était un
marché fermé dès le raisonnement des
conditions favorables
ça marche quand tout le monde les
respecte donc il pourrait que le marché
sera fermé si on part sur ce principe là
sinon il faut que les entreprises
européennes elles aient accès aux mêmes
à renommer novembre j'aurais tendance à
dire aux mêmes ressources que les
entreprises étrangères
sinon vous avez vous avez aucune chance
de pouvoir percer et de pouvoir surtout
avoir une économie à une économie
pérenne du numérique qui tend ferme
quand même ils risquent d'impacter près
de 50% des emplois d'ici fin qu'on en
fait c'est juste le sujet majeur
merci à tous les deux ali j à cyril
d'helmand d'avoir été
avec nous pour évoquer ce lancement
officiel de la hff 5g en france merci